I was gonna say like uh what what was it
like growing up in Philly for you
because we kind of hear so much you know
my co-host DJ damages from Philly
and he would always tell me like about
North Philly and places like Chester
Pennsylvania and just like yeah like
Philly's like that just that area in
general it's a wild place and there's a
lot of videos that have been going viral
recently of like
because fentanyl shit's really bad yeah
right you've probably seen the videos of
people like slumped out like looking
like zombies all over the street and
[__] out there yeah that's right that's
like near where I'm from a little bit by
the way also Happening Here in LA but
you know he
um but what was it like for you growing
up in Philly I mean obviously you were
going to church and you know I'm sure
you were you had a a great childhood but
like was it was it I mean easier or hard
for you to deal with like kind of
staying out of that [__] you know church
was in the trenches yeah like my pop
church was in the trenches bro so it was
like it's not like I had an easy
childhood like [__] as soon as you step
out of church it might be a shootout
type that's what I mean but you were
able to kind of keep it's kind of like
you gotta like
it's a rough neighborhood bro it's easy
to like fall into like it's easy to get
mixed up into that lifestyle right
and it's like you really just gotta stay
out the way mm-hmm like
just stay out the way bro like because
it'll be like you'll be in the way not
even on some dumb [__] you just be in
the way some crazy because where you're
at yeah just like you're at the wrong
place at the right time so what I will
say like I was always focused on music
like everybody knew me I asked fried
like I want some music [__] like you
know what I'm saying like I used to
engineer [__] in Philly producer
[__] like on some studio [__] you know
what I'm saying so
it was just like I was always on some
music [__] and out the way forever so
it's definitely like a rough City though
but you really gotta like just stay you
gotta be focused you gotta be focused
for sure so you don't get fall into you
know yeah
um what do you how do you feel about the
other Trend that's happening in Philly
right now if you think a guy's like too
rare and just like the dance [__] is
going crazy
bro they're having a way yeah they
having their way like it's beautiful bro
to see who's a good kid you guys just
signed
I'm just like
it's like everybody's kind of doing
their own version of the Philly thing
everybody having fun bro like they
brought it like a a fun vibe fun energy
that was missing and that's why I like
afrobeat doing what he's doing like you
be in the club
all these songs about killing and [__]
all this afro [__] come on [__] just
want to have fun and dance bro like I
feel that's why afro doing so good and
even the uh [__] from Philly like they
bringing like Good Vibes back I mean I'm
thinking like even like obviously uzi's
from Philly right so Uzi Like Doing Just
Wanna Rock
it's like the biggest song in the club
for like a year yeah and it's like just
this fun song like
the fun music bro and them regular
[__] too From The Trenches too so like
don't get it like you know what I'm
saying like them they just decide yeah
they focusing on the right [__] like we
don't gotta be on those Street [__]
making songs about violence and all that
ain't just having fun bro did you ever
like uh tap in with like uh like
obviously prior to your generation but
did you ever dive into any of the roots
of music back from back in the day
uh a little bit like black thought's one
of the greatest rappers that ever walk
on the planet you know I wasn't really
on that but I wasn't on that though but
I'm familiar like I know they're Legends
you got a [__] Quest love haven't
played drums on a song or something I
know Questlove you know he's still in
the drums just like yo I'd be an honor
man come and play drums on this yeah
just for Philly yeah for sure but I
wasn't really on them early like I mean
you weren't on them early because you
also weren't alive exactly because being
on them early would have been you were
listening to them because I think their
first album was like 92. huh
yeah I was knowing them a lot and that
album isn't even on Spotify you got to
buy it like on a real the real jump yeah
it's like yeah and then you know Scott
Storage yeah focal store he was in the
roots for real that's crazy I knew that
somebody told me that that's what
started in the roots yeah Legend you got
to get with storage man have you gotten
in with him yet no not yet he's a legend
though let him tell you some stories now
I know he got some crazy asses the
craziest ever
any girl that you think of when I say
this to you right now that pops in your
head
he is true he [__] everybody first so
whatever girls just popped up in your
head yep then everybody everybody
we gotta sit down with skorts gotta go
out to Miami he's going when I heard he
went stupid when he was up and then he
went down but he's back up you back up
right now though yeah he got through it
I heard that story like he used to snack
the amount of money Scott Storage was
spending on just like everything was
just in I mean Jesus Christ God bless
that guy I'm just a legend he's a cousin
Mark [__] with squish we be having a
argument like who better Timbo or Scorch
I'll be going with Timbo
I think it's like Timberland's like top
three ever so his range is insane yeah
Bubba Sparks he could do it I mean he
could do it Nelly Furtado like that's
why he my favorite yeah the the range of
uh of him is insane how you have you
heard anybody try to make an AI version
of yourself yet
no I'm waiting it's gonna happen yeah
I'm waiting I want to hear it though
like yeah like can AI nail your your
tone you know
I mean ain't nothing some others crazy
[__] they are Ellen Rihanna Kanye the
Rihanna Tim's remix that [__] crazy it's
fire yeah
I seen some other [__] it was a
I think it was Cayenne Franco Kanye
singer Frank Ocean joke no Kanye Sunday
Justin Bieber
yeah that [__] was crazy though
yeah it's kind of crazy the AI thing is
getting a little it's getting a little
sketch I hope they I hope they shut that
[__] down though they're not going to
the labels are going to start [__]
they're doing the same [__] the actors
are doing you see why the actors are on
strike yeah cause they're trying to
slide in a little artificial
intelligence into the movies yeah so
like extras like they want the extras to
be like AI like they want to be able to
scan like an actor and then use their
artificial likeliness let's go it's
coming bruh [__] they gotta let go of
that [__] just be a few more years
I think some bull made a song like Drake
featuring The Weekend that [__] hit like
a million the first time oh yeah yeah
that's this was like yeah this was like
what maybe like six months ago seven
months yeah it was recent and that [__]
was that [__] went viral they like this
[__] hard because it's like also not a
bad idea if you're a writer I wonder if
it's a terrible idea to like writers on
there right now writers doing all AI
[__] cause like this is what this is
like let me send this out so like my
thing is if you're a writer and you
write a song for Drake do you send the
AI Drake version to his team speak back
look this is how he would sound I've
seen some [__] like I I don't link with
somebody they got some [__] I can
imagine man like they're not even
writing they invoice no more are you uh
your your process you're are you
straight Melody then punch in or yeah
yeah I'm mentally punching in yeah or
Melody and just think punching Pro Tools
guy when you record yourself logic yeah
wow we just this guy just switched over
to logic right here
I'm Elijah girl I've been online I heard
logic is the [__] though the [__] I've
been on there for like 10 years and you
don't need a license you don't need a
[__] little USB thingy yeah logic a
lot much Logic the wonderful much easier
to get cracked yeah yeah yeah I got a
[__] here Cricket if you're interested
in this in stealing software logic much
easier to steal than Pro Tools no for
sure 100 man